canada's seat of power ottawa occupied
by truckers and their supporters for
more than a week now protesters call it
a freedom convoy the police say it's a
siege on the capitol
in the depths of winter truckers from
across canada are off-road
adamant that kovite 19 vaccine mandates
for cross-border drivers must end
or the prime minister should resign on
monday justin trudeau accused them of
trying to derail democracy
it has to stop
the people of ottawa don't deserve to be
harassed in their own neighborhoods
they don't deserve to be confronted with
the inherent violence of a swastika
flying on a street corner
or confederate flag
or the insults
and jeers
just because they're wearing a mask
the police are turning off supplies of
fuel and funds to put a break on the
protests
a court has also put an injunction on
the loud sound of horns disrupting daily
life
we went after the funding
our efforts combined with the city's
efforts eliminated the gofundme 10
million dollars are no longer accessible
to the demonstrators
but the battle is far from won the
truckers are showing no signs of leaving
i would die on these streets for my kids
and my grandkids to have freedom here
100
there's no doubt like we saw people on
the side of the street with their signs
at 10 o'clock at night
40 below in the weather standing there
with their signs and telling us that
we're their only hope a bunch of
truckers with their hockey sticks and
flags like come on
how did we get here
hundreds of kilometers away from ottawa
at the main crossing between the u.s and
canada there's heavy traffic as
supporters pour in from south of the
border prominent republicans including
former president donald trump tesla
founder elon musk and far-right and
anti-vaccine groups have shown their
support for the truckers
but in canada most people are vaccinated
including many of the protesters
why and it's not because canadians love
getting needles
it's because canadians trust science
canadians trust each other
but these demonstrations show trust in
the government and its rules may be
waning for some
priyanka gupta al jazeera